item number SCP three two - gee Bob
jecht clasp safe special containment
procedures SCP three - nine - j is
currently housed in containment locker
three - 9 - j access is permissible to
all personnel description SCP - three -
9 j is a common American yield sign with
the apparent ability of speech
SCP 3 - 9 - j claims to be a ghost
now our anomalous properties have been
detected at this time the following 3
recordings are interview logs with said
SCP interview log 3 - 9 - J - 1 good
morning 3 - 9 SJ you to oncoming traffic
uh ghost sign do you know where you are
I am in the realm of the living right um
what were you doing before this I was a
sign know I'm a ghost sign what does
that even mean I was once arrested for
driving under the influence what I know
right I don't even have legs drug
driving is dangerous interview log 3 - 9
- J - - good morning uh ghost sign don't
call me that
I'm just a sign now oh hi
why are you a sign now I dropped my gold
slicers your what I can't be a ghost
without my clothes license but how can
you even carry a license well I can't
now I've no longer ghost I
but what interview log 3 - 9 - J - 3
we brought you outside to see if you
affect traffic in an enormous way it's
nippy could I have a sweater or no for
[ __ ] sake you're a ghost you don't need
a sweater shut up you shut up why don't
you make any sense